for several hours yesterday the White
House signal the president was ready to
sign an executive order to withdraw from
NAFTA but after the president spoke to
the leaders of Mexico and Canada he said
he now has no plans to walk away from
the trade deal Margaret Brennan is at
the White House with the different us
options Margaret good morning good
morning well the president is saying
that those mixed messages actually
helped him he tweeted this morning that
the leaders of Canada and Mexico asked
him yesterday to renegotiate rather than
terminate NAFTA that threat of
withdrawal was first floated by White
House officials who said advisor Steve
Bannon was behind it blowing up a free
trade deal certainly fits with the type
of protectionist policies he's known for
but it's a risky game to play with two
of America's biggest trading
relationships so concerned business
leaders including many former Wall
Street executives who now work here
ultimately convince the president to
instead agree to negotiations once
Congress gives the green light and
talking tough on trade is risky today
for example the president is going to
sign a memo scrutinizing China's impact
on the aluminum industry but the
president really needs Beijing's help
when it comes to issues like NAFTA so
he's going to hold his tongue and hold
off on labeling them a currency
manipulator which he promised to do on
the campaign trail